[Music]
what a pretty unexpected twist the
president's decision to ridicule the
leader of North Korea as a little rocket
man turns out to be kind of working out
North Korea has proposed a face-to-face
meeting between the two leaders if it
happens it'll be the first-ever summit
between a sitting American president and
a dictator from North Korea in response
a lot of our foreign policy geniuses
melted down I think frankly it's a
dangerous gamble and a bad idea and in
some ways I can't believe I'm saying
that because for years I've been arguing
that we need to have direct talks
between the u.s. and North Korea I'm in
the more of the you must be kidding camp
the you know we've just given Kim Jong
something for nothing it was a
breathtaking gamble according to one
report do you agree I do it is a role of
a nuclear dice flip reins the former
adviser to Hillary Clinton and former
Deputy Assistant Secretary of State and
he joins us thankfully thanks going on
no thank you for having me so I'll just
be totally honest because why not I have
no idea what this will lead to if
anything you could see it going wrong
you could see it taking unexpected in
positive directions like who knows what
I know for certain is that almost
everybody you just saw on TV is dumb if
has a long track record of one of them
was mentioned actually
yeah I'm sure but every one of those
people has advocated foreign policy
positions that have been a disaster for
the United States repeatedly and they're
never called to account so I guess the
fact that this was unexpected yesterday
should have surprised us why was to
listening to these people well I think
it was surprising everybody and I think
President Trump definitely has an
i-told-you-so in him but I think he has
a fair number of people who work for him
to say I told he said - I don't think
Secretary of Defense mattis or Secretary
of State Tillerson saw this comment that
you're right or thought that the
language last year the tweets were a
good thing so what he did he did
instinctively on his own to the extent
that the establishment got it wrong if
they got it wrong we'll see but it's not
partisan
I mean people I just totally agree with
you I absolutely agree with you and I
have
- I've always thought when I work for
the Obama ministration I hated the way
we handle North Korea I hated the way
Bush did it was always treating them
like they deserve to be treated as an
equal I thought we should just ignore
them yeah right I I at one point wanted
to say if you can't launch a rocket that
doesn't reach you know the outer
atmosphere we're not going to talk about
you but president Trump you know he he
inherited something a little different
he inherited North Korea at a time when
there have been harder to ignore they
have made clearly made technological
advances but yes missiles in their bomb
stuff and he you know six months ago I
would have told you that if we weren't
alive in a year North Korea had
something to do with it and president
Trump's bellicose language of people a
lot of people felt that way and to be
fair and I just want to be honest you're
right a lot of people at his own State
Department the president's own State
Department would have agreed with you
after two drinks in private for sure
so maybe the lesson of all of this is
you don't necessarily need to insult
foreign leaders even evil ones but maybe
you need to think a little more broadly
what we've been doing isn't working and
nobody in Washington is willing to
acknowledge that because they're
implicated in past bad decisions well
shouldn't we go forward that may be more
open mind we should and frankly I
I don't know Anna was surprised that he
agreed to a meeting and agreed to it
fast I mean you know to the extent that
our diplomacy is slow and plotting and
doesn't work right might as well blow it
up we could be sitting here in six
months and having a conversation about
how this was an absolute debacle and you
know you spent a lot of time focusing on
immigration and there have been times in
the last month's where you have not
liked what the president said
immigration true that the Republican
Party has not liked what they hear from
him including on TV yeah and this is
gonna be pretty similar I mean not that
it'll be on TV though let's all hope it
will be but he there are a lot of
stakeholders here for America were all
one at this point because if Kim does
something crazy he's gonna blow us up
irrespective of what party were part of
but you have the South Koreans do you
have the Japanese you
of the Chinese and I know you're always
very interest in the Chinese this is a
problem if he goes in there and he says
I'm a great deal maker you really have
to look at what deals he's made in his
life he tends to overpay well this is if
he overpays for this deal then someone's
gonna suffer and it's probably going to
be someone other than us but Kim jong-un
is not no no I agree this is complex but
what we know is that previous strategies
failed which is why we're here in the
first place so I have an open mind fleet
thank you now you think you'll notice
about that appreciate it